[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle émission et
aujourd'hui nous recevons un invité
exceptionnel Jack Lang bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et avec
moi pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Jack Lang
bonjour vous êtes président de
l'Institut du monde arabe depuis 2013
vous avez avant tout une immense
carrière politique commencé au PS en
1977 vous avez été député député
européen maire de Blois de 1989 à 2000
porte-parole du gouvernement ministre de
l'éducation nationale sous bergovois et
juspin mais pour nous tous vous êtes
l'éternel ministre de la Culture vous
l'avez é dès 81 pendant 10 ans sous tous
les gouvernements socialistes pendant
les deux septénas de François mitteran
on vous doit la fête de la musique la
fête du cinéma ou les journées du
patrimoine le patrimoine culturel et
culinaire vous y êtes attaché comme le
prouve votre menu du jour Jean-Pierre
oui avec un totem de la cuisine
française un pote au feu et en dessert
une omelette norvégienne dans le dessous
des plats découvrez le fast food
maghrébin on vous emmène dans un bar à
couscous et plus largement à la ouverte
de la cuisine orientale dans les pieds
dans le plat la galère des restaurateurs
pour trouver du personnel en salle et en
cuisine comment rendre ses métiers plus
attractif reportage à suivre allez on
passe à table tout de suite cuisine et
confidence alors Monsieur le Ministre
d'abord merci d'avoir choisi ce poteau
feu qui sincèrement nous réjouit avec
Brigitte alors qu'arrivent les premiers
frima le pote au feu est parfait pour se
chauffer le corps et l'âme mais une
question me tur lupine avez-vous bien
saisi le concept de cette émission et
oui quand je vous lis à propos de ce
plat populaire rustique voilà ce que
vous dites le pote au feu c'est idéal
pour travailler sur un dossier h alors
là il y a peut-être même sans doute à
malentendu si vous comptiez nous faire
bosser avec Brigitte sur vos prochaines
expos de l'Institut du monde arabe sous
prétexte que l'on déguste un pote au feu
je vous le dis monsieur le ministre
c'est raté pas question qu'on se plonge
dans les poème de Jean
Sénac pour les tables rondes prévu le 17
novembre non politique à table est une
émission monsieur Lang plaisir gourmande
alors s'il vous plaît déconnecteter ce
pote au feu du boulot et racontez-nous
plutôt votre passion pour cette macreuse
cette queue de bof qui fond au milieu
des carottes dans un bouillon parfumé et
faites-nous entrer dans les coulisses de
l'histoire est-ce que vous partagiez des
pot au feu en 1981 avec le président et
mitéran et tout le banc socialiste dans
son fil F du Morvent oui mais je luis
même préparer c'est vous qui prépare bon
j'aime j'aime cuisiner je suis pas un
grand cuisinier mais j'aime cuisiner et
j'aime la
cuisine rustique la cuisine
traditionnelle la vraie cuisine du
terroir j'aime aussi les recherches mais
bon le pote au feu moi dans ma famille
c'est un plat traditionnel depuis depuis
toujours et dès que l'hiver approche en
effet le le je le prépare avant je il
est bon que le poteau feu dorme un peu
un jour ou deux ah oui ah oui le
bouillon avant je fais le bouillon non
le bouillon les viandes et mais de jours
avant pour que ça ça laisse ça se ça
m'asser un pe ça m'asser un peu et puis
il faut du temps en effet quand je dis
que je bosse où je travaille je
gratouille pendant que le poteau feu se
prépare prenez l'exemple de la queue de
bœuf qui est un élément de base du
poteau au feu qui donne un parfum un
goût une saveur il faut
5h ou 6h pour pour soit T la jou buf
c'est dur aussi c'est un peu moins dur
c'est un peu moins dur mais bon alors en
même tempsi j'aime ce qui caresse les
PAP non seulement les papis mais aussi
les narines le palais et là le parfum
des légumes du laurier du thint des des
légumes m'enchante et ça me donne de du
punch qui vous a appris à faire le le
pot pour pour écrire pour travailler qui
vous a appris à le faire vous avez pris
une recette vous êtes inspiré d'un grand
chefè était une très bonne cuisinière ma
grand-mère maternelle aussi et ma
gourmandise était le principal moteur
vous êtes gourmand ou gourmet je suis
gourmand et peut-être gourmet alors on
va le goûter ensemble vous allez nous
dire si c'est un bon pote au feu ou pas
si vous y retrouver les les pièces de
viande que vous avez l'habitude de je
vois à l'instant et ça c'est un bon
point pour moi pour le chef c'est qu'il
a il y a mis de la que de bœuf peut-être
pas assez pas tout à fait assez cuite
qu même un peu dur parce que le secret
d'un po au feu et plusieurs viandes
différentes gélatineuse un peu maigre
c'est ça vous faites quoi comme ch c'est
quoi votre choix votre panaché ça dépend
on discute avec le le boucher mais là
vous avez réuni jou de bœuf plat de
côte pardon du palerond Mause paleron
c'est une merveille ouais mais là encore
ça réclame une cuisson lente et et est
longue il faut mettre ça dans l'eau
froide ou dans l'eau ou parce qu'il
paraî qu'il y a deux écoles et que Paul
bocus mettait dans l'eau froide des
histoires histoires je pense faut pas
évidment croyez pas Paul bocus non c'est
ce qui est stupide c'est si on met des
légumes brutalement dans l'eau glacé
alors on les saisit on le fait du mal de
l'eau disons de l'eau tiède ou froide ou
chaude et alors les légumes qu'est-ce
que vous avez l'habitude de mettre
légumes bon comme ici donc carottte
j'entrevois navé pomme de terre mais
aussi poireaux il y a il y a trop très
trop peu de poireau euh bon un peu de
thint un peu de
laurier parfois on sa bien voilà et puis
ce qui existe dans la saison du moment
puis là il y a l'au samile est-ce que
c'est indispensable pour c'est
indpensable parce que l'au sal moile
donne un goût apporte avec la avec la
que buf un
goût fort et bon simplement la l'au
àamoile le problème c'est qu'il il faut
l'envelopper pour être sûr que le
bouillon parte pas aussi non pour être
sûr alors qu'il parte pas et pour être
sûr que le gras n'envahisse pas la
totalité du ah d'accord et le Selle vous
le mettez pas au même moment que la
viande vous le mettez plus tard d' les
légumes ce n'est pas non plus au même
moment que la viande ou il y a tout un
timing précis pour ce qui permet entre
les deux ou les trois ou les quatre de
travailler et d'avoir une bonne cuisson
de de tous les de tous les éléments
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a des ça excite
tous les sens c'est vrai c'est vrai bon
on est très excité visite aussi un peu
le pote au feu alors trois astuces pour
roquer le pote au feu oui exactement on
peut le revisiter on peut faire par
exemple monsieur langue un pote au feu
en mode faux vous savez cette feu cette
soupe vietnamienne alors vous ajoutez
des clous de girofle du gingembre des
graines de Corion de l'étoil de Badian
qui donne un goût un peu anisé des
oignons de printemps puis même un peu de
gocman cette sauce de poisson et là vous
allez avoir un poteau feu qui va avoir
des petites saveurs asiatique c'est
assez sympathique vous devriez essayer
mais là-dedans il faut mettre aussi dans
le poteau au feu dit français et faut
aussi des clou de girofle il faut mettre
aussi et quelques un des ingrédients que
vous avez évoqué à l'instant sû
exactement alors après on on n pas
obligé on peut se passer du bœuf hein si
le bœuf ne vous fait pas d'effet on peut
on peut faire des pot au fe oui on peut
faire un pote au feu c'est une méthode
de cuisson on peut le faire à la
volaille au lapin on peut faire au veau
saucisse de Morteau pote au feu et même
si vous voulez pas de viande vous pouvez
faire même un pote au feu de lotte avec
des petits légumes et cuit dans le
bouillon et puis enfin on peut aussi
sortir du tripticque qu'on vient
d'évoquer navet pommes de terre et
carottes avec d'autres légumes des vieux
légumes Panet topinembour ou alors des
patates douces ouais ou des pomes de TER
alors des pommes de terre c'est souvent
dans le potaueu classique non un un plat
voisin que que j'adore et qui qui varie
de de province en province c'est la poté
ah oui alors dans mon pays d'origine la
poté
Lorine la laorine la poté laorine alors
le le lar il était très présent et alors
vous avez donc ça c'est un plat que
vousit vous faites régulièrement
régulièrement régulièrement pe pas le
seul quand même alors vous avez d'autres
effectivement parce que vous êtes
souvent en cuisine c'est ça chez vous
quand je su chez moi c'est je cuisine ma
femme me fait confiance elle a peut-être
tort j'aime ça et puis le dimanche
généralement c'est mes ma fille mes deux
petits fils qui quelques amis et bon le
matin je vais au marché c'est un bonheur
le marché regarder déjà sentir savourer
humer et puis je me mets à au fourneau
entre guillemets vers 11h mais quand
c'est un P feu je l'ai préparé le samedi
ou même le vendredi et alors vous
arrivez au marché et vous vous vous
laissez tenter par ce que ce que vous
voyez ou vous partez déjà avec votre
petite liste de souvent je fais à
l'avance mais par exemple j'aime
beaucoup cuisiner le poisson et le
cuisiner simplement au courbouillon le
saumon le bar d'autres poissons colollin
que j'adore j'adore le Collin avec et
après une petite sauce ou juste comme
oui non c'est peut-être alors par
exemple je je garde le côté des des
Moris sèche que je mélange avec un peu
de de crème c'est
simple ça pe-être une mayonnaise mais
all léger généralement avec des blancs
d'œuf là vous mélangez avec des blancs
d'œuf absolument h mais est-ce que vous
cuisinez à l'instant ou vous aimez bien
un livre de cuisine et vous suivez étape
par étape où vous avez une espèce de de
de de petite imagination et vous partez
comme ça dans le vide non j'ai pas
beaucoup
d'imagination sur ce plan là en tout cas
et nager j'adorais lire les livres de
cuisine pas mais pour les lire pour les
lire c'est une passion de même que
j'aime lire les
dictionnaires viux j'adorais ma mère
avait le vieux Larousse de cuisine
d'avant- guerre que j'ai toujours chez
moi de temps en temps je c'est ça qui
vous inspire ou est-ce qu'il y a des
grands chefs par exemple qui vous ont
aussi inspiré dans dans vous votre
cuisine il a des grand chef que que
j'aime que j'admire je serais pas
capable si je devais citer un nom je
dirais Michel Guérard pour moi c'est le
grand mê c'est lui qui a ouvert la
cuisine à à la à la vérité à
l'authenticité plus c'est un homme
merveilleux et généreux bon j'aime aussi
pour d'autres raisons à la Ducas et hier
il nous avait convié quelques amis à un
dîner amical de tous ceux qui l'avaient
aidé à réaliser ce que vous verrez d'ici
un an ou un an et demi une sorte de
Maison de l'Artisanat et restaurant à
Clichy h dans une maison qui a été
conçue par un un ami de Nancy aussi Jean
prouvet qui fut un grand architecte
constructeur et le président du du
centre beauourg vous avez de belles
inspiration alors ça donne quoi après
vous en cuisine alors la poté vous nous
en parliez le pote au feu quels sont vos
autres pl signature les les
signaturesagéront
pas l'important pour moi c'est la
qualité du ce que je je peux acheter la
cuisson bon le poisson est souvent très
présent le souffl ou les souffl au
fromage au fromage principalement ou au
fromage au pluriel parfois ou
quelquefois les soufflés sucrés au
chocolat parce que ma femme aime
passionnément le chocolat voilà et puis
et puis aussi les fruits mer et puis
aussi voilà vous avez une palette assez
variée finalement oui oui alors quel
terroir a façonné votre goût et vos
inspirations parce que vous l'avez dit
vous êtes né dans les vuges mais vous
avez été aussi longtemps mer de Blois
donc leur et Loir qu'est-ce qui vous a
le plus marqué dans votre ADN de cuistau
sur le plan culinaire
oui naturellement c'est c'est que c'est
l'enfance l'adolescence
oui mais c'était au-delà de des plats
trad i Laurin
disons la quiche comme on dit ou ou le
paté Laurin qui est une merveille mais
il faut savoir le faire ça aussi très
c'est une entreprise héroïque où c'est
un gâteau admirable comme le succès
qu'on retrouve maintenant dans beaucoup
de pâtisseries
parisiennes donc mon inspiration elle
vient surtout de la Lorine et
éventuellement bon de la mère quand même
de la parce que partie de ma famille est
originaire de de de Bretagne de
Vendé alors par exemple la côriade autre
autre j'aime beaucoup les soupes
finalement h la Cotter c'est un plat
breton je pense de poisson c'est une
potée de poissons plus bouill à baiss de
mais mais bretan bretonne les plat SAF
tout ce qui est à base de
soupe m'enchante par exemple
euh dans beaucoup de pays vous trouvez
l'équivalent mais avec les produits du
pays poteau feu colombien que dont je me
souviens don le nom m'échappe qui est
absolument admirable mais qui est
réalisé avec les produits de de Colombie
de Colombie
[Musique]
euh il y a d'autres pays comme ça qui
vous qui vous inspirent que dont vous
appréciez particulièrement la cuisine ah
non mais ça c'est autre chose m'inspire
je suis pas je suis vraiment un amateur
je suis pas un cuisinier non alors je
suis en effet passionné par les cuisines
du monde les cuisines du monde bon je
veux pas établir de hiérarchie ce serait
très prétentieux mais je dirais que la
cuisine en tête dans petite échelle de
valeur la cuisine japonaise ah
euh la cuisine marocaine la cuisine
maghrébine en général on en parlera plus
tardou on va en parler ouais bon la
cuisine chinoise j'admire son
extraordinaire dextérité son incroyable
diversité selon les régions mais elle
est un peu parfois un peu lourde quand
même mais quand même c'est une grande
cuisine euh et puis même les pays dont
on parle peu ont cha ont chacun des
choses pas l'Allemagne on a longtemps
dit que c'était un un endroit où on
mangeait mal c'est vrai c'est faux quand
vous allez déguster une
fabuleuse saucisse à de Munich avec du
réfor alors le réfor est un de de mes
condiments préféré qui ça vient ça vient
de je sais pas de par relation avec
l'Alsace avec d'ailleurs chez moi vous
viendriez en réserve j'ai trouvé un
endroit où on peut se procurer assez
bien une dizaine de préparation de
réffort euh c'est très bon ce qu'on peut
déguster en Allemagne Allemagne aussi la
Forêt Noire aussi la Forêt Noire bien
sûr et même dans les pays de l'extrême
nord en Suède ou en Norvège et l'Italie
alorsal l'Italie souvent pour les ce qui
est merveilleux pour l'Italie c'est la
simplicité c'est c'est où qu'on aille
c'est pas le cas en France je v pas
ouvrir les polémique c'est pas le cas en
France où qu'on aille en Italie on mange
bien on mange bien ou c'est vrai une
cuour du produit que vous devez
apprécier particulièrement Absolum et
puis ils ont un respect du consommateur
donc il y a pas d'attrape touriste
vraiment en Italie peut-être qu' dans
certaines ville comme Venise on peut se
faire avoir mais globalement c'est
toujours une ass raison raison bon
l'Espagne un pays incroyable enfin il
faut faire le tour du monde ça tour du
monde culinaire est merveilleux puis y a
les pays je le connais pas euh mais
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'éblouissant pour la vie cette cette
relation à la cuisine mais au de la
cuisine à la vie à la nature au
euh aux légumes au votre façon de
consommer a a évolué avec les années
parce qu'on on dit qu'aujourd'hui il
faut pas manger de de viande tous les
jours alors que à l'époque on c'est vrai
que on on en donnait beaucoup et
notamment aux enfants parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de de protéines vous vous
avez vous êtes devenu un peu flexitarien
comme on dit
oui peut-être j'ai été
influencé par les par les temps par les
temps nouveaux entre
guillemets mais moi je consomme moins de
viande qu'avant et les les légumes me
passionnent beaucoup h alors juste une
toute petite question quand je vous
entends parler comme ça de la cuisine je
on n' pas souvent l'habitude de vous
entendre parler de ça vous avez été
ministre de la Culture vous nous avez
fait une fête de la musique pourquoi
vous nous avez pas fait une fête de la
cuisine mais on a fait des tas de choses
qui sont mal connues à la fois comme
ministre de la Culture et ministre de
l'Éducation j'ai créé en son temps un
Centre national des arts culinaires qui
associé plusieurs ministères concernés
par la qualité de la cuisine le
ministère de l'Agriculture le ministère
de l'Éducation le ministère de oui la
culture je crois que le premier
président de ce centre national
culinaire ce fut
Robuchon ou ou ou ou Michel Guérard
enfin l'un et l'autre l'ont été et nous
avons impulsé toute une politique par
exemple d'initiation au goût dans les
écoles en lien avec un homme admirable
qui s'appelait monsieur puisé un homme
qui a tour avait créé un institut du
goût nous avons avec un autre ami créé
en lien avec le CNRF un série de livres
qui mériterait d'être réédité sur les
savoirs culinaires traditionnels région
par région région par région r euh et
ainsi de suite ça c'est un peu perdu à
l'école vous avez pas l'impression qu'il
faut réenseigner les légumes la façon de
consommer la façon de manger je essayé
de le faire quand j'étais ministre
d'éducation nationale on a on a on a
multiplié les classes de goût on
a j'ai essayé d'agir sur les sur la
c'est pas souvent l'État qui le décide
ce sont les communes mais on a essayé de
les de les de les inciter à choisir la
qualité la qualité de produits locaux en
particulier pour les faire découvrir aux
enfants estce que c'est toujours
effectivement une question très très
d'actu
de consommer local parce que les les
cantines ne sont pas toutes très bonnes
ça progresse ça progress peux pas vous
dire j'ai pas fait d'enquête récente
mais mon intuition me dit que ça s'est
plutôt amélioré cro alors avec ce
poteaufeu vous mais c'est un vrai sujet
et avec Michel Guérard don nous parlions
nous avions aussi mené une réflexion sur
la restauration collective c'estàdire à
la fois les les les lycées les écoles et
cetera mais aussi dans les hôpitaux et
dans tous les les et on a obtenu et
lui-même avait créé d'ailleurs à un
moment donné dans son lieu dans dans le
Sud-Ouest une école de de pour la
restauration collective alors avec ce
pote au feu vous nous avez demandé un un
vin de Loire un un un chinon euh on est
en c'est du cabern et franc évidemment
et puis euh c'est un millésime 2017 avec
donc une robe légère quelques nuances de
grena on peut voir et des arômes de
fruits rouges euh c'est une appelle
question que vous aimez particulièrement
je crois qu'il a eu un malentendu mais
ça ne fait rien ça ne fait rien j'aime
beaucoup le vin de Chinon non non
j'avais proposé c'est une erreur parce
que j'ai été député j'ai été maire de
Blois et député du département de
loircher j'avais proposé de choisir un
un un un Gamet de de de la du loirch ah
alors on c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
mais ce qu'on peut dire simplement c'est
que c'est 20 qui a voici 30 ou 40 temps
était pas pas toujours très savoureux on
gagnait en qualité en raffinement
partout et dans le monde entier dans le
monde entier par exle de l'Allemagne
tout à l'heure mais il y a des vins
allemands
fabuleux vous vous avez entendu que en
Angleterre même oui euh ça c'est pas
forcément une bonne
nouvelleer les aneces politiqu je ne
trouve pas facile
j'ai en mémoire un vin d'Angleterre que
l'ambassadeur de Grande-Bretagne nous a
offert lors de la visite de la reine
Élisabeth à Paris au dîner d'État et il
avait un vin anglais ah ouais qui ma
fois était assez
bon ça s beaucoup amélioré encore oui et
ça va encore s'améliorer on va voir si
vous êtes vraiment incollable à présent
et c'est le
quiz vous êtes Brigitte lad président de
l'Institut du monde arabe et que serait
le monde arabe sans le lukum dites-nous
si ces affirmations à son sujet sont
vraies ou fausses le monde entier
découvre le Loum lors de l'exposition de
Nice en
1906 qui qu'est-ce que je dois dire
question c'est vrai ou faux est-ce que
c'est vrai ou pas bah que le monde
découvre en 1906 je ne sais pas du tout
ce que je je ne suis pas sûr je que
lukum viennent d'abord des pays arabes
je pense que le lukou vient des pays
comme la Turquie plus plus orientaux qui
en plus ça a été ensuite ça s'est
développé bien sû ça s'est répu mais le
bon vrai lou c'est pas si fréquent alors
vous avez alors vous répondez non c'est
pas en 1906 qu'on le découvre alors en
fait la démocratisation non c'est plutôt
c'est avant c'est en
1873 lors de l'expo universel de Vienne
elle reçoit une mdaille d'argent et
effectivement c'était un confiseur
d'Istanbul parce que c'est oui mais
c'est la tradition ottomane qui a on
peut donner un point on peut donner un
point pas complètement nul alors le
premier Lou est connu était confectionné
avec du sucre de l'eau de l'amidon de
blé et de l'eau de rose je croyais qu'il
y avait du plan d'œuf aussi non alors
non je je peut-être que l'amidon de blé
pouvait permettre de faire le lion de
l'œuf donc on va dire oui allez bon à
l'étranger les plus grands amateurs de
cette douceur ottomane sont les
Allemands c'est possible je n'en sais
rien j'en sais rien c'est faux c'est en
fait les Anglais dès la fin du 19e
siècle le louum colonise la culture
britannique il y a même la fameuse
multinationale du bonbon 4atre Burry qui
avait essayé de lancer un lou industriel
mais il se sont plantés et enfin la
reine éliizabeth toujours la
Grande-Bretagne adorait les lukum
contrairement à winon churchield qui les
détestait vrai ou
faux je pas capable de répondre je
dirais oui VO non faux parce que Wion
adorait aussi les lou il adorait tout
cigare la bonne bouff c'est un mangeur
un bouffeur un jouisseur il aim les
lou alors on va parler de la tête de
veau maintenant cher à votre adversaire
politique JAC Chirac et à moi qui est
une des spécialités des vauges
sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont exactes le berceau de
cette recette est saint-ier
desvuges vrai ou faux crois pas c'est
faux rambervillier où se déroule la
foire aux têtes de veau je suis allé
c'est vrai alors cette foire a lieu le
lundi de pâqu vrai ou faux ça je ne sais
plus alors c'est faux c'est 15 jours
avant pâqu il faut être très
fort il existe même une confréie des
goreg gousteur de tête de veau je ne
sais pas mais je veux bien en faire
partie parce que çae j'aime la tête de
de V mais la vraie de vrai je sais pas
si vous allez parler de la vraie de vrai
he alors comme ça existe on va leur
faire signe pour que vous soyez intégré
à cette confléie les gbregux gouur de
tête de veau voilà et puis la sauce
gribiche qui accompagne la tête de veau
est à base de cornichon
dur ail et échalote oui une sorte de
mayonnaise avec sa pas très bien un
petit peu mais il y a pas d'ail il y a
pas d'ail non donc c'est pas une aolie
moi qu j'aime tellement la tête de veau
que je ne prends pas d'Oli ah oui je
l'aime la tête de veau natureae la dév
nature quand elle est bonne et la tête
de veau bonne trouve pas partout hein on
en trouve pas non c'est très difficile
c'est très très difficile la tête de vaô
peut-être écuré certains de vos
auditeurs elle doit être cuite à l'os
totalement cuite entière
et il y a très très peu d'endroits je
connaiss m un endroit
saintouan un restaurant merveilleux où
il chaque mercredi on pouis la déguster
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui alors je vais
vous faire une je sais pas si j'ai le
droit de le faire je le fais tant pis
une confidence j'ai un de mes amis qui
est un un gastronome un ami passionné de
cuisine qui s'appelle Robert rlinger qui
me pardonne si je cite son nom qui adore
la tête de veau et nous n nous
débrouillons pour trouver un chef qui
nous la prépare à la manière ancienne
c'est-à-dire à l'os et c'est le chef ah
Rud varen Passard Passard voilà Passard
ça peut vous paraître bizarre oui parce
qu'il fait des légumes maintenant par il
a fait sa mu hein oui il fait des
légumes parf de temps en temps il y a
aussi les les les crustacés le reste et
en même temps c'est franchement c'est un
homme qui a une virtuosité
extraordinaire il sait tout faire et
alors on a fait réalisé c'est lui
replinger qui a fait réaliser la tête de
veau par par Passard un jour lourd en
croûte de
sel l'important c'est la cuire elle
étouffée oui une autre fois dans une
marmite au vin jaune qui qui a dû lui
coûter cher quand même vous connaissez
ça le vin
jaune une autre fois avec des des
feuilles de de muûrier ou deou de je ne
sais très bien de murier ou de enfin je
sais plus c'était très bon à chaque fois
dans T les cas cé bon mais alors les les
clients sont terrifiés ouis quand quand
le le le chef apporte la tête de VO
entière c'est assez impressionnant c'est
très impressionnant alors c'est
souventour d'un bon repas que se nou les
deals politiques que se fait la petite
et la grande Histoire et c'est la brève
de
comptoir alors c'est souvent
effectivement autour des des des
déjeunés des dîners qu'on se raconte les
meilleurs histoire finalement on vous a
demandé jackl de réfléchir à
éventuellement une anecdote que vous
pourriez avoir j'imagine que vous avez
fait des tas et des tas de déjeunés et
de dîner politiqu est-ce que par exemple
vous avez une un souvenir à
nous j'ai pas vraiment réfléchi mais
puisque tout à l'heure on évoquait ce
dîner avec la reine d'Angleterre à
l'ambassade de
Grande-Bretagne le c'est un souvenir là
assez assez douloureux et émouvant donc
ce vin d'Angleterre nous servi et
c'était la fameuse année horibilis je
crois que c'est
1992 et la reine nous étions qu ou C à
une petite table avec François mitteran
et le le son époux
elle nous
a livrer sa sa sa
douleur sa souffrance qui était
absolument étonnant de la part d'un
personnage qu'on disait toujours très
retenu très réservé c'est une marque
j'allais dire d'affection qu'elle avait
pour Fr mitéran de confiance
confiance'est qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a
dit quels ont été ses mots je nai pas en
mémoire exactement les mots mais ce qui
était touchant c'est qu'elle nous parle
et qu'on sente en elle cette cette
souffrance qui avait été la sienne
pendant plus d'un ans cette fragilité
aussi h cette humanité h et François
miteran m'a dit d'ailleurs après le
dîner vous savez j'ai rencontré souvent
la reine il l'a rencontré à Londres
l'inauguration du tunnel sous la Manche
et ca elle est
gentille pour moi le mot gentil est un
beau mot h alors qu' alors qu'on la
présente parfois comme comme comme comme
rche comme un peu dur mais moi j'ai eu
la chance de l'accompagner de 3 jours
lors de ce voyage à Blois à
Chambord à Bordeaux nous attendit le
leur bateau là le le le
Britannia c'était une femme en effet
dans le privé tel que je l'ai vécu
sûement j'ai été chanceux délicieux
exquise exquise alors comme vous
travaillez à Lima à l'Institut du monde
arabe et bien nous nous sommes
intéressés à la cuisine du monde arabe
et vous allez voir qu'elle est riche et
varié c'est le dessous des
plats et oui Brigit des pays du Maghreb
jusqu'au Proche Orient en passant par la
péninsule arabique on déguste cette
fameuse cuisine arabe élégante raffinée
et riche de multiples saveurs avec des
plats qui sont devenus cultes chez nous
comme le couscous et ces fameux mésés
ces petites entrées qu'on partage c'est
un reportage de Clément perouau Bonduel
et de sopia
Mazar le couscous a désormais sa version
fast food ils fleurissent un peu partout
en France on les appelle les bars à
couscous le principe est simple
explication avec Bader installé à Paris
près de la gare saint-lazar on peut
composer son couscous comme on en a
envie donc en choisissant les légumes
les tailles les semoules les viandes
c'est dans l'air du temps tout est
optionnable aujourd'hui on peut tout
composer un peu comme comme on en a
envie et pourquoi pas le couscous j'aime
bien
navé çaon poon ou on part sur carottes
potiron oignon navé et poisiche ça part
c'est plus le côté chaud et réconfortant
pour cette journée pluvieuse après qu'on
puisse choisir évidemment c'est un plus
et emporter encore plus pratique des
fois on aime bien varier et puis j'aime
pas quand s imposer
aussi de changer le topping la viande
non je trouve c'est bien pour la sauce
norm et tout en haut du H parade des
garnitures ça va vraiment être les
mergais alors même si il est vrai que
les mergises c'est une invention les les
mergises on n jamais de eu de couscous
mergais que ce soit au Maroc en Algérie
ou en Tunisie c'est vrai c'est vrai on
doit l'avouer avec ou sans mergise le
couscous reste le plat oriental le plus
populaire en
France mais une autre cuisine du monde
arabe loin du Maghreb tire depuis des
années son épingle du jeu c'est celle du
Liban et ici le grand classique
l'incontournable c'est le hummous c'est
la purée de poisiche c'est de la crème
de sésame ou la tahini de l'eau et du
jus de citron et à ça on vient ajouter
notre mix notre mix spécial de balila
donc c'est des pois chiches cuits avec
des concombres en Saur des herbes
fraîche de la cbette le homous classique
il est toujours sur la carte il bouge
pas toujours sur la carte en compagnie
des MZ ces entrées à partager qui ont
popularisé la cuisine libanaise je pense
que c'est vraiment cet aspect du partage
qui fait le succès et aujourd'hui les
gens ont envie de venir et de passer un
moment de partage cette variété permet
aussi de plaire à plusieurs personnes et
de ne pas sentir qu'on est bloqué avec
ce qu'on a commandé je pense que c'est
uneine qui a un bon rapport qualitéprix
pour le
déjeuner c'est une cuisine aussi assez
conviviale pour partager donc les gens
aiment bien bien se retrouver ensemble
pour manger libanais rien qu'à Paris la
cuisine libanaise compte près de 250
adresses souvent jackl si je vous
amemène dans un bar à couscous il y en a
plein qui SM à Paris qu'est-ce que vous
mettez dans votre bol après la smoule
quels sont vos ingrédients votre
garniture préférée les viandes et cetera
j'ai compris que en vous voyant devant
l'écran pas de mergise pas de mergise
non non c'est il a raison ce monsieur là
bravo il ilavoue d'ailleurs son
forfait je j'u Bergis alors que ça
n'existait pas peut-être ça existe
maintenant en Algérie au Maroc ou en
Tunisie mais pour vous c'est une hérésie
c'est Mo je c'est une
hérésie elle est même commise à
l'Institut du monde arabe alorsz je suis
très franc avec vous alors qu'est-ce que
vous mettez comme ingrédient dans votre
couscous idéal pour pour moi le le plus
plus important c'est la qualité des la
qualité évidemment du couscous lui-même
la semoule la semoule moi j' une semoule
assez c'est assez grosse assez d'utes
très fine bon les légumes évidemment
sont roi
euh il faut pas les les coupur en petits
morceaux il faut qu'ils arrient en
pleine
souveraineté et les viandes les viandes
mais on peut s'en passer moi je trouve
qu'un couscous de légumes
s s'il est
merveilleusement épicé préparé c'est un
plat complet donc pas forcément de pas
forcément d'agneaux pas forcément
le méchoui c'est pas mal quand même un
bon c'est autre chose méchoui c'est
c'est une des viandes qu'on peut mettre
avec le C oui mais mais ce qui est bon
c'est un vrai méchouion prépare et que
l'on déguste ensemble on dévore avec les
mains que l'on euh moi un agneau qu'on
fait guéillé ça ça c'est c'est génial et
les petits poisiches les petits raisins
sec un peu c'est bien c'est bien ça
agrémente un peu les choses vous
connaissiez le principe là du du
baracouscous vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne idée c'est ça je connais pas pour
dire la vérité je vous me donner l'idée
et je vous remercie je vais y aller pu
ce monsieur est sympathique je vais y
courir ouais il faut il faut y goûter
est-ce que c'est un de vos plats
préférés comme comme les Français adore
le
couscous j'aime le couscous c'est pas
mon plat préféré si vous voulez j'aime
assz j'aime beaucoup les dans la cuisine
marocaine la cuisine algérienne ou
tunisienne mais ce n'est pas le couscous
à lequel je me précipite d'abord ce sont
les les les les tajines les tajines de
de viande les tajines de poisson
c'est les soupes aussi pardon je reviens
au soupe la CHBA ou ou la comment
dirait-on au Maroc la ah bon peu importe
c'est le même principeou
euh et puis certains desserts comme euh
ça on en parlera tout à l'heure des
desserts pard et et alors ces tagin il y
a aussi des la claque et les les les les
maghrébains notamment les les Algériens
les Marocains aussi les tuen cuisine
admirablement les poissons il cuisin au
four il cuisin en tagine les cuisin je
sais pas ils ont une façon avec avec les
aromates avec les épices il préservent à
la fois la qualité de la chair ils
trouve le moment juste de cuisson et
c'est parfumé de admirablement vous
aimez le côté aussi salé sucré qu'on
peut retrouver dans certains t j'aime
sans plus j'aime j'aime sans plus oui
par exemple c'est clair que les les
plats marocains et algériens je crois au
pruneau son sont bon enfin c'est pas ou
ouai c'est pas ce que vous préférez et
la cuisine arabe c'est aussi la cuisine
orientale on parle souvent de la cuisine
libanaise parce que c'est sans doute une
des meilleures du du de cette région
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça ou
oui je pense quand même que les deux
cuisines dominantes je être offensant à
de personne c'est la cuisine marocaine
qui pousse à
niveau c'est lié à une histoire c'est
lié à beaucoup de choses et la cuisine
libanaise mais n'oublions
pas celle qui a été la maire de toutes
les cuisines de l'Orient tout à l'heure
on l' évoqué à propos du du du lukum du
lum c'est la cuis la cuisineutom la
Turquie de l'Azerbaïjan jusqu'au Maroc
on mange turie la Turquie bon n' pas
pour rien était l'Empire ottoman pendant
4 siècles donc elle n pas pu ne pas
inspirer les cuisines même de de de
l'Europe centrale et ce fameux homos
qu'on voyait dans le dans le reportage
ça on le retrouve partout au moyen
aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment il a voyagé énormément et et
les més euh les M ça c'est bon le le mot
je crois pas che les Libanais enfin
c'est ce sont les Libanais qui et les
Turcs aussi les turc c'est peut-être les
Turcs à l'origine je pense
historiquement hein bon c'est c'est
merveilleux d'avoir des petits plats de
toutes sortes que on peut picorer comme
le disait la dame dansre reportage ça
crée une atmosphère de de immédiatement
de partage et de convivialité et puis on
a le choix hm hm et alors à l'Institut
du monde arabe dans le restaurant
marocain qui a été créé ils ont aussi
c'est Jamel de bous qui a été un des
inspirateurs ils les ont cré ta maman
qui é au fourneau aussi elle au début
elle était là souvent c'est une femme
merveilleuse que j'aime beaucoup en ce
moment elle n'est pas là je le j'espère
qu'elle reviendra bientôt elle c'est une
femme délicieuse elle a aidé beaucoup à
à affiner la la qualité du couscous mais
ça c'est pas marocain les mé donc on n
mange pas dans ce ils appellent
m parce en réalité au Maroc vous avez
des des petits hors d'œuvre
bon merveilleux souvent qus sont vos m
préférés du monde arabe ils appellent
improprement m ouais enfin c'est pas
grave alors c'est quoi vos min préférés
c'est les petites feuilles de vign c'est
les petits poivrons farcis c'est la
petite viande les petites c'est quand
ils sont bon
voilà et vous aimez un peu ce ce côté
finger F enfin où on peut vraiment
manger grignoter passer
d' d'ailleurs je je pousse
cela à travers une manie don j'ai du mal
à me défaire c'est que j'aime utiliser
ma cuillère et ma fourchette pour puiser
m plat PL central ou
c'est mais c'est comme ça un vrai
couscou c'est au centre tout le monde se
sert ce que fait notre ami dans ses ces
couscouses individueles c'est bien aussi
a c'est le cas aussi à du monde Arab il
sont excellents mais le le vrai couscous
oui mais ça c'est dans les familles vous
imaginez au restaurant mettre un plat de
couscous et tout le monde tape dedans je
pense que non ça peut être le cas être
une grande table grande table mais c'est
un plat familial oui c'est comp mais les
Chinois aussi aiment bien les Chinois on
met tout autour de la table ça tourne et
pu ils aiment bien ça ils ont en France
effectivement on est un peu plus chacun
se pour soit on a été marqué par les des
siècles de monarchie et qui ont
introduit d'ailleurs beaucoup de choses
belles et bonnes euh la fourchette la
fourch on dit que c'est Catherine de
mdicis qui de l'Italie hein ça vient
d'Italie qu'on vu dans cette émission
donc c'est vrai que par exemple les à la
Révolution française lorsque les les
princes ont été écartés du pouvoir les
cuisiniers euh euh leurs cuisiniers sont
devenus des restaurateurs h et ont
contribué à cette cette excellence de la
cuisine française et quand vous vous
voyagez ou quand vous revenez vous êtes
content de retrouver cette cuisine
française qui on se lasse jamais ou pas
oui ou pas parce que parce que tout à
l'heure nous le disions je veux pas du
tout être négatif mais aller au hasard
dans un restaurant c'est très difficile
en France aller au hasard dans un
restaurant en Italie vous êtes sûr
d'être bien reçu h alors au Parlement
vous savez qu'on on parle beaucoup
d'immigration et notamment de la
régularisation des étrangers dans les
métiers en tension comme la restauration
alors a-t-on besoin de cette main
d'œuvre étrangère on en parle et on met
les pieds dans le
plat des restaurants fermés
principalement pour cause de de manque
de main d'œuvre et bien ça ne fait plus
exception la restauration n'attire plus
en dépit de Sala en hausse les horaires
à rallonge et le stress du service
détour les jeunes de ces métiers comme a
pu le constater Clément per et Ivan
anavion lesescal est une institution le
plus grand resto routier de France
installé près de châurou sert tous les
jours de 400 à 600
couverts tous les jours mais plus toute
l'année désormais l'établissement
connaît des périodes de fermeture je
suis obligé de fermer l'établissement
une semaine la semaine prochaine par
manque d'effectif manque de personnel
particulièrement en salle plus personne
ne veut servir plus personne ne veut
travailler surtout le soir le weekend
c'est c'est catastrophique voilà
monsieur bonjour de couvert si vous
voulez bien mess par ici longtemps
ouvert 2424 l'escale ferme désormais à
minuit pour les mêmes raisons et alors
qu'il a la clientèle pour les remplir le
patron est contraint de laisser
certaines salles vides tu es triste hein
et et et si j'étais seul à constater ce
truc-là mais
un collègue là de à côté là il ferme
tous les dimanches depuis le 15 octobre
à cause de manque de personnel moi ça
fait 45 ans je fais ça je suis pas mort
l'escale propose à ses serveurs un
salaire de 14,50 minimum de l'heure
c'est 2,20 de plus que la moyenne de la
profession mais ça ne suffit pas à
susciter des vocations en cuisine aussi
la pénurie de main d'œuvre se fait
sentir bonjour tout le monde là ça va
ramer P du déjeuner pour travailler ici
il faut dépoter et apprécier
l'adrénaline de
Ch courire partout être dans le jus
c'est passionnant pourquoi toujours
depuis que j'ai 13 ans et ça changera
pas
j'adore faut aimer sinon on aime pas on
peut pas tenir c'est pas possible
oui une FR en s'il vous plaît
artine du chauffeur
pression horaire contraignant salaire
pas toujours mirobolant la restauration
n'attire plus en salle les habitués sont
au courant des difficultés que
rencontrre lesescal chacun a son avis
sur la question c'est normal trouve pas
du personnel on ararrête pas le r donner
tous les mois de l'argent rester chez
eux les gens il veulent plus travailler
chez les jeunes faut pas grandchose pour
pour être dégoûté re vignant je trouve
maison ça c'est mon avis les métiers de
la restauration c'est mal payé vous
commencez à 10h vous finissez à minuit
vous rendez compte si vous avez des
enfants des choses comme ça c'est
impossible à gérer
actuellement l'escale cherche à recruter
CIN serveurs en salle et trois
cuisiniers Jack Lang est-ce que vous
avez pu constater vous cette tension qui
peut y avoir dans la restauration est-ce
qu'à Lima par exemple vous êtes concerné
c'est un vrai sujet c'est vrai c'est un
vrai sujet et je crois que que les
les les autorités ont raison de de de
favoriser la le le maintien la
régularisation pardon des des personnes
qui travaillent dans ces métiers euh
c'est quand même le minimum minimum donc
pour vous en fait c'est ce fameux
article 3 hein du projet de loi
immigration il faudrait qu'on puisse
régulariser automatiquement euh toutes
les personnes illégales dans les métiers
en
tension c'est c'est mais c'est c'est
c'est je dis pas je veux pas entrer dans
le détail technique mais je veux dire je
trouve un peu un peu nul làb de de pour
des raisons euh peut-être purement
politique de soullever une telle
question c'est une évidence que nous
avons besoin de ces personnes pas
seulement dans les métiers de la
restauration mais dans les métiers de la
santé dans les dans les hôpitaux dans
dans les dans les partout des gens qui
par ailleurs apporte une compétence un
engagement un dévouement extrême ça pas
créé un appel d'air comme le dit la
droite sont des bêtises absolues vous
imaginez que un pauvre homme qui souffre
dans le désert de de de de l'Afrique
pense à l'article 3 lorsqu il pens qu'il
y a un monde meilleur en France avec des
travaux à la clé
donc sans doute mais c'est pas un
article de loi qui le fait venir ou pas
venir ça rend la France plus attractive
non pour non ça rend surtout ça préserve
des métiers ça préserve des des
entreprises des entreprises de
restauration les entreprises de toutes
sortes et je crois que c'est vraiment
c'est très mal d'avoir j'espère
d'ailleurs qu'à l'Assemblée nationale on
va rectifier le tir mais pourtant c'est
on veut aller plus loin que la
circulaire Val c'est pourtant un
gouvernement socialiste c'était sous
François Hollande qui avait mis quand
même des gardesfous en disant que
c'était l'employeur qui devait faire la
demande et pas le salariés ça ça devrait
changer et puis qui avait aussi laissé
au préfet la main pour décider certes
mais euh tous les gouvernements de
gauche nont pas toujours fait les
meilleures choses il ont fait de bonnes
choses de très bonnes choses mais ils
ont plus se tromper puis puis le temps a
changé en tout cas je donne mon avis
personnel et c'est le sentiment de tous
les professionnels de tous les gens qui
tous les des des utilisateurs de de de
ces lieux non il faut absolument revenir
à une situation sage raisonnable il y a
quand même encore plus de 7 % de chômage
en France donc il y a des Français qui
pourraient exercer ces métiers vous
pensez que les Français ne veulent plus
faire ce genre de métier c'est une
situation de fait que vous avez
aujourd'hui en France je pas en mémoire
les chiffres des près 3 millions de
chômeurs ah oui 3 millions de chôummeurs
je sais mais je le chiffre que je
n'avais pas en tête c'est c'est le
nombre de non français qui occupe deses
métiers je pense que si demain déjà on
ne trouve pas c'est une évidence mais la
droit dire au lieu de donner ses au lieu
de donner ses Jobs à ses à ses sans
papierers ou à ses migrants donnonsles
aux Français qui sont au chômage s'ils
viennent il les auront je veux dire non
il y a parfois aussi je pense dans
détail des choses que je connais pas
bien mais il y a aussi des conditions de
travail des conditions de
salaire que je connais et d'horaire
aussi d'oraire d'horaire par exemple je
suis je connais oui je connais vraiment
des gens qui travaillent très tôt le
matin et qui terment très tard le soir
c'est pour ça est-ce que c'est les
Français aujourd'hui ne veulent plus
accepter ce genre de de travail ou
est-ce que tout à c'est aussi assez
inhumain et de se dire que c'est pas non
plus normal qu'un étranger exerce faut
s'attaquer à à ses hires à cette
organisation du organisation qui
qui est assez assez dur et assez assez
difficile à vivre pas qu pour le pour le
famille pour leur enfin c'est c'est
vraiment je pense que cette question qui
a été soulevée elle devrait être réglée
d'une manière non pas sous la forme
d'exclusion mais sous la forme de de
d'une mesure sociale concernant
l'organisation du travail et les
salaires alors les salaires ont augmenté
de plus de 16 % dans la restauration
plus de 16 % l'année dernière et
pourtant ça n'attire toujours pas donc
c'est vraiment l'organisation qu'il faut
revoir sont des métiers très difficiles
écoutez franchement moi je comme je suis
moi même un un amoureux des bistr des
restaurants je je vois comment il bosse
et il faut beaucoup de courage de temps
et puis et et ne pas avoir de famille
parfois h ne pas avoir d'amis ne pas
avoir d'activité vous sacrifierz une
partie en tout cas bon dans une certain
il faut régler cette question de manière
sage et et pas et pas politicienne
humaine humaine voilà humaine vous avez
trouvé le bon mot vous avez entendu dans
ce reportage un des un des un des des
clients qui dit en fait il y a beaucoup
de gens qui préfèrent rest rest chez eux
parce qu'ils sont mieux payés est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait faire une
différence entre plus grande différence
entre les revenus du travail et les
revenus de
l'assistance c'est c'est faux ce qu'il
dit c'est faux les revenus de
l'assistance ne sont pas si élevés qu'on
le dit c'est un en partie une légende et
puis il y a des gens qui sont assistés
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas travailler
alors si on veut mettre dans des bistr
ou des restaurants dans des hôpitaux des
personnes qui qui ont un handicap
provisoire faisons-le non il y a une
part je trouve quand on est homme
politique ou femme politique il faut
c'est pas une question de droite et de
gauche selon moi c'est une question de
responsabilité ne traitons pas les
choses comme ça pour tenter de plaire à
d'ailleurs je suis convaincu que les que
les citoyens de base quelques sur leur
opinion partage le sentiment que
j'exprime à l'instant et qui sera
développé ou retenu par l'assemblé
national c'est ce que disent les
sondages ou effectivement dans une
certaine gauche Brigitte aujourd'hui
monte un droit à la paresse qui
revendiquer vous qui êtes la gauche old
fashion vieille école est-ce que vous
revendiquez ce droit à lapparisse moi je
considère comme new
fashion pard par non je
plésente le droit oui le droit le droit
à la jouissance le droit au plaisir le
droit au plisir le plaisir c'est pas
tout à fait pareil mais pas tout à fait
pareil non mais le droit à la pariss
vous le revendiquez et cette valeur
travail qui a moins d'importance chez
les jeunes comment vous le voyez comment
vous le sentez oui ça c'est ça c'est une
à étudier c'est vrai que que c'est un
changement de mentalité assez fort qui
se produit alors on dit que c'est lié au
covid peut-être c'est vrai que dans tous
les sujets que je connais pas seulement
celui-là il y a eu un changement de
comportement il y a des gens qui
n'acceptent plus des
emplois trop dur ou sils ont la
possibilité d'avoir des emplois aussi
bien payé ou même parfois moins bien
payé mais moins
asraignant j'imagine que les les
autorités il travaillent mais on dit oui
les jeunes ne veulent plus travailler
c'est pas des tir au flan aagéront pas
on vit de slogans de de de de de
grandiraton les jeunes quand il ont la
chance de pouvoir faire des études
passionnantes ou ou de de d'être engagé
dans un métier excitant et ils bossent
ils travaillent ils aiment ça mais ils
veulent un peut-être un meilleur
équilibre entre leur vie professionnelle
et leur vie personnelle peut-être et
après tout ils ont raison ils ont raison
alors on a fini on va passer au dessert
et c'est le pécher
mignon alors brigitte jackl a voulu une
omelette norvégienne ça a été créé en
1867 par un chef qui s'appelait Balzac
c'était le chef du Grand Hôtel qui a
voulu créer un dessert un peu
scientifique il a voulu montrer que le
blanc d'œuf donc la meringue puisque
c'est du blanc d'œuf cuit en fait est un
isolant entre la chaleur donc il y avait
une génoise qui était flambée et de la
glace si vous mettiez une meringue entre
les deux et bien ça ne conduisait pas et
on pouvait préserver donc autant dire
que c'est quand même compliqué il y a de
la glace du flambage c'est tout un CIRC
même ce restaurant ce plat iconique ce
dessert iconique a disparu
progressivement des tables alors nous on
va vous servir une omelette norvégienne
qui n'a plus grand-chose de
norvégienneim sinon le nom non mais
faites pas la fine bouche pardon faites
pas la f bouche c'est une petite
omelette norvégienne contenu des
dispositions de cette cuisine d'accord
si elle arriv pourquoi je vous ai alors
elle est pas flambé on est désolé mais
vous m'avez demandé entre deux portes si
je dire quel quelle plat je proposer non
je pense qu'on doit réhabiliter je suis
pour je suis pour l'innovation je suis
pour la recherche la découverte de
nouvelles saveurs évidemment mais le
pote au feu nous l'avons évoqué et
l'omelette norvégienne c'est un plat que
j'ai connu quand ma mère était ma
cuisinière si j'ose dire c'est un plat
beau d'abord alors il est pas comme ça
pardon il arrive là il vient il vient de
la grande distribution c'est une sorte
de montagne
blanche qui qui est arrose de alors
selon les endroits dans mon pays c'était
de Mirabel ah oui et qu'on fait flamber
donc le plat arrive flambé oui donc
c'est déjà une spectacle c'est interdit
ici hein oui et puis comm vous l'avez
très bien expliqué c'est C trois trois
couches c'est une génoise qui le fond du
plat une glace et des des blanc d'œuf
alors le tout évidemment et le réaliser
une il faut que ça se tienne enfin faut
que ça se tienne est-ce que votre maman
vous a légué la recette de l'omelette
norvégienne est-ce que vous vous arrivez
à reproduire cette cette recette là je
je sais encore la faire voilà faire ou
je sa la faire qu'on trouve quasiment
pas la à la carte des restaurants
aujourd'hui trou alors je connais un
restaurant puce qu'on a le droit de
faire la publicité pour les restaurants
là encore c'est mon ami Robert replinger
qui est un gastronome et qui je sais pas
s'ils le font régulièrement ou s'il le
font à la demande c'est le rest le Louis
XI ah bah avec un nom pareil il peut
faire l'omelette voilà c'estpque oui
mais est né après Louis XI d' comme vous
l'avez très très bien dit elle n'est pas
norvégienne du tout alors mais vous
savez pourquoi alors j'ai une petite
anecdote parce qu'en fait le fameux
Balzac le chef il voulait rendre hommage
à un physicien qui avait imaginé ce
blanc d'œuf qui n'était pas conducteur
et qui était installé en Bavière et le
pauvre Balzac qui croyait que la Bavière
c'était en Norvège alors il a baptisé
son omelette omelette norvégienne
d'accord donc en fait une
omelette
c'est c'est c'est on peut le croire
parce que le le blanc le blanc des
neiges Le Blan des
GL la glace
même c'est mer et et j'allais dire les
si on va jusqu'en Islande les volcans
qui flambent ouis c'est ça donc le gar
le gars en question avait de
l'imagination connaissais pas la
géographie mais il avait de
l'imagination très bien il a pressenti
les
chosesors réhabilitons ce type de plat
ça vaut pour beaucoup d'autres choses
qu'on le euh
notamment pour les desserts je trouve
que il y avit des PL anciens qui qui
étai d'une saveur
extrême en T les cas c'est nouveau
combat de Jack on a bien compris pas un
nouveau combat c'est un combat permanent
permanent alors vous savez qu'on termine
toujours cette émission en musique on va
écouter celle que vous avez choisi et
vous nous dites ce que c'est juste
après
Philipp glace c'est ça Einstein and the
beach glace Philip pH glace un
compositeur américain qui est un des
inventeurs de ce qu'on appelle la
musique
répétitive et qui accompagne en
particulier je crois à nouveau bientôt à
la Villette une mise en scène de Bob
Wilson que nous allons contribué à faire
découvrir à NANC il y a une vingtaine
d'années Einstein on the beach
personnellement j'aime la musique
répétitive pas seulement fil gllace
j'aime les musiques traditionnel je sais
pas par la musique ballinaise ou la
musique africaine parce qu'elles sont à
base de souvent de répétition de de
rythme j'aime beaucoup aussi la musique
électronique une partie de mes goûts
musicaux et grâce à vous nous avons la
fête de la musique et on vous en
remercie merci en tout cas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation Jack langang
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
[Musique]
LCP
REACH